pour l'an 2000 en france une ligne
imaginaire longue de 1200 km doit relier
la ville de dunkerque à celle de
barcelone en espagne une ligne
concrétiser par des arbres comme une
méridienne verte confectionnés par des
dizaines de milliers d'enfants chargé
des plantations premiers arbres de cette
méridienne à dunkerque planté ce matin
dunkerque survolé par daniel wolfromm et
michel levasseur la méridienne verte
commence ici à l'aplomb du sémaphore du
port de dunkerque
au delà elle traverse la france de part
en part pour passer les pyrénées jusqu'à
barcelone 1200 kilomètres plus loin deux
siècles après la mesure de ce que l'on
appelait alors la méridienne de paris le
long de cette ligne imaginaire
plus de dix mille arbres vont être
plantés de manière discontinue
à l'image de ces jeunes chênes dans le
parc du fort de dunkerque
les essences chêne châtaignier ou
olivier ont été choisies pour leur
longévité supérieure à 200 ans
aujourd'hui c'est bien la sainte
catherine et selon le dicton tout bois
prend racine clin d'oeil rêvée pour
madame trautmann la ministre venue avec
monsieur le maire michel delebarre le
préfet et les enfants des écoles
participer à cette fête dans la pure
tradition laïque et républicaine
c'est une façon de partager un acte et
des initiatives qui relève au fond de la
citoyenneté et de la confiance par
rapport à l'avenir pour les jeunes qui
sont ceux qui plantent le plus d'arbres
aujourd'hui
et bien moi je pense que ça s'enracine
dans le deuxième millénaire pour se
projeter
vous serez là pour le pique nique au 14
juillet le clou de cette opération est
bien ce rendez vous le 14 juillet 2000
le long de la méridienne verte pour
participer à un incroyable pique nique
c'est son nom officiel